what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of new DC news
to go over some of it is a little bit
controversial and some of it is really
really big now you might have heard
recently that Warner Brothers Executives
were okay with keeping Ezra Miller on
board even after everything that's kind
of happened with him well today we have
a little bit more clarity on that which
we're about to dive into but we also
have a little bit of an update about DC
and its future when to expect a full
release of its movie slate coming up and
kind of what to expect from it if you've
been following the channel for a bit you
know that I think DC is about to make a
really big comeback with James Gunn and
Peter Safran in charge now and here's
kind of the biggest thing that you need
to know about DC Studios and Warner
Brothers Discovery right now and that is
yes James Gunn and Peter saffron are
rebooting the DC EU which it's no longer
called anymore it is officially called
the DCU James and Peter have a vision
they have a a vision of what they want
for the next 10 years now I'm sure a lot
of people at DC had this before but here
was the problem Warner Brothers and
Executives would interfere and the
problem with this is when Executives get
involved they're not always the biggest
fans and they're not always focused on
making the best content and of course
continuity in the universe now many DCU
fans have noted that studio interference
is kind of what derailed the previous
attempt at the dceu and kind of made it
really messy and is basically what made
it unsuccessful one fan stated this
online and James Gunn replied to him the
person stated as long as the studio
doesn't override you and your directors
at every turn I for one have confidence
that you'll actually be making decisions
for the DCU that I can get on board with
in my opinion worth exactly nothing it
was Studio interference that derailed
the previous attempt at a DCU it
wouldn't surprise me to learn that Mr
Johns was quite frustrated this was
posted on Mastodon in which James Gunn
replied the position is different than
it was with Zach Etc Peter and I are the
heads of DC Studios the only Studio
interference would be from us so
basically there's a new structure over
at Warner Brothers Discovery they now
have an official DC studios in which
Peter and James are the heads of so
basically they have final say in
everything and the reason that's so
great is because James and Peter are the
ones solely creating the future for the
DCU they are Road mapping everything
right now and they have created what
they call the DC Bible and what's really
awesome is that James Gunn has recently
said on Twitter that he has mapped out
the next eight to ten years of the DCU
in which he also revealed that they are
going to be revealing some of that this
month now I'm assuming that they're
going to go in phases as well like
Marvel Studios does after all James Gunn
has worked very closely with Marvel for
many many years now with the Guardians
of the Galaxy franchise and I think he's
going to bring a lot of what he learned
from Marvel Studios over to the DCU so
of course we would not expect him and
Peter to release the entire eight to ten
year plan for DC what we should expect
this month however is probably the next
one to two maybe three years of the
dcu's future to be revealed in which we
know a little bit about we know that we
can expect to see Superman and Wonder
Woman Within the first three years of
the DCU however of course like most
people know we are not going to be
seeing Henry Cavill Superman it also
looks like we will not be seeing gal
gadot's Wonder Woman either now
yesterday variety came out with a report
stating that Wonder Woman will not be in
the first three years of the new DCU in
which James Gunn has actually debunked
so it is confirmed that we will see
Wonder Woman in the DCU in the next
three years and she most likely isn't
going to be played by Gal Gadot and
here's the reason why and here's what to
expect from the first one to three years
of the DCU yes a reboot not entirely of
course I'm assuming characters like
Peacemaker are going to remain but as
far as the Justice League is concerned
yeah pretty much an entire reboot James
Gunn stated that the reason that Henry
Cavill isn't going to be playing
Superman in the DCU is because they're
going to do a Superman Project where
Superman is much younger so that pretty
much tells you a lot about the plan
right there they're going to start the
Justice League from scratch with younger
characters which is a great move we're
going to start off with these characters
they're going to be introduced to us
when they're young we'll see their
Origins I'm sure see what they do in
their youth and of course over the next
eight to ten years they'll grow up their
stories will progress they'll come
together as the Justice League and
pretty much the storytelling and the
Cinematic Universe will be very in sync
and have a lot of continuity which the
old DCU did not have and is pretty much
the main reason that it failed now
speaking of a DCU Justice League reboot
a lot of people have been talking about
Ezra Miller lately this is due to a
report coming from variety they say that
some Warner Brothers executives are open
to the idea of keeping Ezra Miller as
the Flash and yes they are talking about
keeping him after the flash releases on
June 16th of this year 2023. now this
has a lot of people up in commotion
right now because Ezra has gotten into
quite a bit of trouble recently and the
reason that it's very controversial is
because when Johnny Depp got into a
little bit of trouble they fired him
right away and then Johnny even went on
to win the trial against Amber Heard but
he still hasn't been brought back and
Amber Heard wasn't fired from Aquaman 2.
so this is why it's very controversial
of DC however when James Gunn debunked
the rumor about Wonder Woman not
appearing in the first three years of
the DCU stating that she would be he
also claimed that he didn't know what
the report about Ezra Miller was about
also keep in mind what he said before
him and Peter are in charge of DC
Studios the executives over at Warner
Brothers Discovery don't really and
can't interfere with his decision making
so if he doesn't want Ezra Miller to
come back as the flash Ezra's gone and
that seems to be the case as James Gunn
is doing a Justice League reboot and
even Insider Daniel rpk recently said
this on Twitter here's the thing they
said Executives have no problem keeping
Ezra that's their mistake those
Executives don't matter only Gunn and
saffron those same Executives wanted
Henry Cavill to come back and play
Superman again we saw how that turned
out and that's 100 percent correct for a
really really long time Dwayne Johnson
fought for Henry Cavill to come back as
Superman and then when the change came
at Warner Brothers Discovery and there
was new people in charge the new people
in charge did agree with Dwayne and let
Henry Cavill come back as Superman we
saw this in Black Adam however that was
before James Gunn and Peter came in and
became in charge of DC Studios once they
became in charge they changed everything
and now Superman is not back Henry
Cavill won't be playing Superman at
least not anytime soon so despite
whatever the executives want the great
thing is is it comes down to what James
and Peter want and I think that that is
truly what's going to make this DCU
different from the DC EU Peter and James
are true fans they know the source
material and the best thing is is they
have great proven track records as
filmmakers as directors as writers so I
do have faith in them also they never
said that Henry Cavill won't be back a
Superman they never said that Gal Gadot
won't be back as Wonder Woman it's just
not in their immediate plans because
like I mentioned they are going to start
with younger versions of these
characters however when they grow up you
never know what can happen plus not to
mention they are probably going to
introduce the Multiverse at one point in
time and when this happens it's going to
be a great opportunity for all of these
characters to return and it'll be really
cool when it does happen a new Superman
meeting with Henry Cavill a new Batman
meeting with Ben Affleck not sure if the
new Flash will meet with Ezra Miller
will have to wait and see on that and it
sounds like it's pretty much confirmed
that Jason Momoa is going to be playing
Lobo now in the new DCU so that would be
really cool to see him meet with Jason
momoa's Aquaman so these characters
could return although they are not going
to be the main Justice League anymore I
do look forward to the day that James
and Peter introduced the Multiverse and
we see them once again so this month we
are about to hear from DC we're about to
hear the first two to three years of
what they have in store for us with
their movie slate also shows of course
and video games James Gunn did say that
some video games are going to be
canonically connected and we're about to
see all of this really really soon and
I'm really excited but let us know how
excited you are about this in the
comments down below also if you have any
concerns about the DCU let us know down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to stay up to date on all things
relating to the DCU for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf